what is happening there reject nation
tara erickson is back with me today
after i covered in kanto so many people
were like you gotta do turning red next
and i was like okay it's a movie about
like a 13 year old girl that's all i
pretty much know something to do with a
panda i need someone who's really in
touch with their youth so i brought my
55 year old friend tara erickson by to
watch us you excited tara yeah i am
excited you can see how young i am by
these overalls
yeah it really captures the
1950s you grew up in guys leave a like
if you can that'd be very much
appreciated also full length watch along
as we sync up with the time code for
turning around will be at our patreon
page thank you to all who have joined us
over there so far your support means a
lot follow tara erickson on all the crap
that i've linked in the description box
and pin comment she's only here for
attention let's do it and the prepper
boys thanks for helping us edit this
down now let's really do it
[Music]
the number one rule in my family
honor your
parents the least you can do in return
is
every single thing they ask
be careful
honoring your parents sounds great but
if you take it too far
well
you might forget to honor yourself
very true true
i don't have that problem
[Music]
[Music]
euphoria
it's heaven
my mom cuts his hair at the salon and i
felt it it's very soft
he looks like a hobo a hot hobo
[Laughter]
and aaron t and aaron z are like really
talented too
we are four townies remember
oh my god i miss boy bands
[Laughter]
and here is your reward
99 australian tour o
m g mirror i'll guard it with my life
did they say omg in 1994
i don't think yes
[Music]
clueless was like in the 90s oh yeah
okay never mind of course they said omg
what is wrong with me
that's such a common thing
responsibilities man i have
responsibility yeah
check it out oh
that's my little scholar the ancestors
would be so proud
our most revered ancestor
was a scholar poet and defender of
animals ever since the red panda has
blessed our family good fortune and
prosperity and can bless yours too
i'm sorry you grew up white
can't relate to any of this
come on dad's making dinner
[Music]
disney knows how to make food look so
good every freaking time i'm like are we
in ratatouille again yeah look how
delicious that looks oh
why are we not eating right now
fourth down we'll be kicking off near
north american poor
oh my gosh who are these hip hoppers and
why are they called four town if there
are five of them
wow she erases into the trash
wow
she really is an
a-type personnel
i don't get what mir sees in him he's
not that cute
okay his shoulders are kind of nice his
eyes are
oh no
it's just an infatuation man
it's not gonna last
you're not even an adult
oh my god she's glad clothes from fatal
attraction
do you want a snack cool great thanks
don't look at the notebook
who is he did he do these
things know
that hat
is that
the sketchy clerk from the daisy mask
oh my god what tight
oh my god
it's gonna get violent he's a sweet
innocent child how dare you take
advantage of her mom
no
what are you thinking mom god mom oh my
god
why is he a mermaid
this will never
happen again no girl
but it will
toronto man some repressed [ __ ] up in
there
oh my god what what is this love crafty
and crap what is going on here
oh my god it's begun
[Music]
are you sick is it a fever a stomachache
chills constipation
did the red peony bloom no
huh what maybe
but it's too soon don't worry meimei
i'll get everything you need
oh oh i just got it
[Laughter]
a hot water bottle and
pants oh cool i love that pixar's dude
i did not expect this
something to be embarrassed about mom
you are now a beautiful strong
flower i never thought i'd see a pixar
movie where they have that conversation
that's just crazy man
blows my mind woke
woke
hollywood
talking about things every woman goes
yes
so the pandas are just a big metaphor
for female puberty
right
i don't know
extra snacks
and herbal tea for cramps it helps relax
you i got it thank you bye
there's so much i could learn as a man
from this movie maybe the red panda is
who she actually is this is just a front
for her mother god
tyler is an insecure jerkwad end of
stone
[Music]
oh there you go huh uh may
why are you staring at carter murphy
mayhew i wasn't
no
tyler is putting these up what they're
everywhere
[Applause]
alone it's like the movie black swan
[Laughter]
oh god
oh my god
tell him
oh red panda
[Music]
be careful
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening to me
what is it
what's happened already already
what did you say
you know a little
warnings would have been very beneficial
our ancestor son ye had a mystical
connection with red pandas she loved
them so much
that she asked the gods to turn her into
one
the gods granted her wish
they gave her the ability to harness her
emotions to transform into a powerful
mystical beast
protect her village and save her family
from ruin
cool sunny passed this gift to her
daughters and they passed it to theirs
but over time our family chose to come
to a new world
and what was a blessing became
an inconvenience
yeah a little has that would have been
nice yeah
it happened to me you'll undergo a
ritual that will seal your red panda
spirit
into one of these
you only have one chance to banish it
and you cannot fail
otherwise
you'll never be free
hmm
be the 25th that's a whole month away
we'll wait it out together
and i will be with you every step of the
way
you have to accept your emotions
guys what are you doing go away are you
okay tap if you can hear us
two for now
[Laughter]
four times coming to toronto
all right i'm gonna let go and you're
gonna be chill
chill
hey
i'm sloppy i'm smelly
my mom won't even look at me and
no four towns go
go become women without me
oh
that's sad i'm never not by
all right we love you mae you're our
girl yeah no matter what panda or no
panda
they adjusted her being a panda remark
really quick
and you look amazing red looks so good
is it gone for now but if i get too
excited it'll come right back out
something feels
different abby hit me
you can come with us to four towers yeah
i can't ask my mom i'm a furry digging
time bomb
crap you guys better go but no butt
smear my mom already doesn't like you
she doesn't oh
ready
said orangutan
your second place spelling bee trophy
the important thing is you tried you
spelled your little butter first place
in our hearts oh she needs nurturing
just go to the concert as a panda when i
start to get emotional all i do is
imagine the people i love most in the
whole world
which is you guys
oh
oh
i just have one teeny tiny favor to ask
no absolutely not
oh man
i just want to broaden my musical
horizons and it's not worth jeopardizing
your life over right jin
see your father agrees no concert god
damn it dad there's no way she could
keep her panda in and 200
unbelievable i saw that look where did
she get that from treating her own
mother like that me it's your mother i'm
not here oh it's generational i know
about maymay i was just about to call
you no one knows anything they barely
saw her i'm on my way
with reinforcements no i can handle it i
can
you guys need to stand up to your mom's
man
sometimes she's just so
[Music]
no wonder mae is such a loser
eat him come on
eat her
panda
yeah
they don't trust us anyway then what's
the point wow this is our first step
into womanhood we'll say it's a
sleepover at my house my mom will never
know
now we just got to raise the money for
tickets
come on girls think karaoke use the
panda a little panda abby come on mate
it'll clear my mind ha
mermaid
[Music]
get it right i'll give you anything
money my kidney my soul yeah
[Music]
cool
monetize the payout
[Music]
oh my god i want those sticky earrings
[Music]
those are 90s greg i know right
it felt like a real song from the 90s
mom is gonna look under the bed and it's
all gonna go to
[ __ ] when she's just learning to embrace
herself i mean i love it but find a
better spot than under the bed
nice cat are you a triangle cause you
were cute
i want to throw a sick birthday party
an epic one if you're there everyone
will come simple as that i've done you a
favor keeping my mouth shut all i'm
asking for is one bet you're a
manipulative little dick you know that
man oh
do it tylers are always jerks guys 200
bucks will put us over the top hey dork
bag we're in okay i'm heading off to
mathletes wouldn't you rather hang with
dad oh let's get my flash cards oh crap
but i don't want you to
find ellie
oh [ __ ]
oh they want to see the oh no it's scrap
oh god
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you better guess that party man oh god
run each time you do the stronger it
gets and then you'll be bound to it your
mother and i were close once i couldn't
bear to see that happen to you so no
more panda it wasn't the panda you were
your mother's whole world mimi
i know you do what's right
oh jeez constantly guilted man hey tyler
you want the panda you're getting the
panda
let's hear it
oh
god
[Music]
no bueno man
mimi needs a strong hand now more than
ever don't let her out of your sight
i won't mother
it's not the panda girls it's your
possessive nature
right yeah that's what i was trying to
say okay good
picking up on things i'm a man so i
don't understand things you're getting
closer
uh see under the bed like i said
it's not a good spot
oh her grades are failing
mimi
what is
we are walking into that concert girls
and coming out
women guys i can't be like this forever
my whole family would freak
especially my mom all her hopes and
dreams are pinned on me no four towns
the same night is the ritual no
the same night
the same night you want your money then
get your butt down here now go back to
your psycho mom and and your creepy
temple you freak
oh you little racists
what is going on here i am so sorry we
haven't caught you never to have good
thoughts before
i don't know what came up i don't want
to hear your apology
no one mentioned this is a horror movie
man
we just wanted to see four town four
town you manipulated her for a bunch of
tacky delinquents no she wanted to don't
you blame her
she is a good girl and you've taken
advantage of her mate tell her oh may
speak up
leaving her friends in the dust
[Music]
you gotta kill your mom how many tickets
three please
what is that
um
i think it's coming from the skydome
mother
four is the worst number
hurry up everyone it's almost time to
stop the ritual the red moon is about to
begin
oh dad buy her the tickets people have
all kinds of sides to them the point
isn't to push the bad stuff away it's to
make room for it this side of you made
me laugh
it's kind of horrifying
[Music]
and return the red panda spirit
from where it gains
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now destroy toronto
[Music]
oh my god i'm going to the concert
uh-oh is mommy's red panda gonna come
out now
[Music]
this is a disaster uh-oh
she's out of control oh yeah
[Music]
oh snap panda wars
pretty cool that's dope
[Music]
ah you never needed to buy a ticket
losing you guys feels even worse
well too bad or down forever for town
forever forever
tyler
no tyler i don't know what time are a
four tony yeah
[Laughter]
who cares what's she gonna do ground me
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god what is happening
they are gonna destroy tyrande
oh my god it's not gonna be them it's
gonna be our mom
this is so unexpected
what is going on right now
[Applause]
oh
i told you she was big
oh my god i'm shutting this down
everyone go home where are your parents
put some clothes on
[Applause]
this finale is so much bigger than i
thought
[Music]
wow
mom you have to get in the circle
sunny give me strength
[Music]
oh my gosh poor mimi grandma i am not
losing my daughter don't just stand
there
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is
[Music]
sky baby
i hurt her
who
my mom
i got so angry and i and i lost control
oh that's where her scar's from
guide you
and keep you safe maymay's keeping the
panda it's her life
you guys did so much property damage
um
the farther you go the prouder i'll be
people still talk about panda apocalypse
2002
you ready let's do this
hello welcome to our temple and the only
one that's home to the great red panda
monetize your daughter
[Laughter]
i'll be back before dinner okay
fine oh um you're welcome to join us
for mr lee's cooking uh yeah don't load
up on jump thanks for covering for me
you've all got a messy loud weird part
of ourselves hidden away and a lot of us
never let it out but i did how about you
i'm batman
i got real snotty there uh there's a
point where i was real really
crying there i'll get you uh
some toilet paper i think my fingers
will do and these overalls every movie i
watched lately i ended up crying
everything every movie huh why chicks
why do they feel the need to disguise
themselves
did you like it i did it wasn't a
typical like star movie
it took a second it was a little slow
but i liked it i liked the message at
the end that little repressed bully
like
in the beginning you know in pixar
movies
it literally takes them two minutes for
you to super care about the
the lead character basically something's
really traumatic to me yeah yeah it's
just like the a type of like disney
thing we get it this just took a
different path but i enjoyed it i think
that's why i called it slow in the
beginning because i was like well where
is this going i think there was more
opportunities for jokes in the beginning
but i liked it it's a different kind of
pixar movie and i enjoyed it it's weird
they do things that maybe aren't as like
traumatically heft i would say
yet there is a certain type of more i
think
relatable type of trauma that a lot of
us go through as adults that we don't
realize it's funny because i was i was
just speaking with a friend of mine uh
yesterday at the
the moon night premiere
[Music]
marvel cool just saying i gotta
i attended that
[Laughter]
vlog with the kazoo i'm like where is
going with this very long punch nobody
had any idea it's the i went to the
thing and um what's up with my friend
wendy pointedly from the movie couple
channel i'm half asian and i grew up
with my asian family and then wendy's
foolish one thing i was we were talking
about was like i've never seen such a
different type of generational gap like
a specific type than with a lot of and
maybe just because i grew up asian uh
but with like asians from asia and then
like asian americans or
toronto right because the culture is so
different of like it's so disciplinary
and hardcore and i think that it goes
further beyond than just like asian
culture in this like this is something
that i think a lot of people struggle
with but that whole conundrum of
of uh you know like a lot of times you
know if you're not from you know imagine
still happens in asia too but everyone
out here that i would always meet has
that same thing of like my parents are
like this
and i feel the need to like be more
expressive and be myself and get in
touch with my emotions and not just go
down the path my parents want me to go
down and that's a common
type of argument i see happen or it's
the other side where they do feel like
they go down that path but they don't
really want to yeah all asian parents
are bad or something so this is
something i i notice around here in
california and so seeing it represented
here was uh interesting but i think they
still managed to make it universal
because i think we all know what it's
like yeah we have to just be obedient to
our parents i mean it was pretty obvious
with like the even though tyler wasn't
in it a lot but he is the bully that was
like a suppressed like with all this
repressed anger a bully and then he
turns into one of their like one of the
girls and he likes uh oh town i keep i
want to say oh town it's four town but
it's modeled after ohtown from 2001.
yeah you guys remember ohtown and i'm
like oh that's the perfect example of
like tyler was like you know he's a
bully because he had all this like
repressed stuff i think disney pixar
especially has been dealing a lot with
re generational repression mm-hmm that's
why i just would just watch the
encounter you've seen a kanto right yeah
and like that had the same thing but
like yeah that was this one
grandma lineage and like oh it stems
from there of trying to satisfy and
please or go down a certain path but a
lot of it is
leads to unintentionally forcing your
children to repress
the way they feel it's like this yeah
lately it's like this message of like
psychological embrace and accept
yourself it's been like a lot of the
message i think i've seen people
sometimes say with this movie i've only
i didn't know what it was actually about
me neither but i've heard some of the
things of like that's not as universally
accessible usually hearing this from men
and i thought that like okay so what is
it no it is
not experience emotions like a teenager
i'm like i still think this is pretty
relatable even for me i'm like no
there's a lot i can relate to in this
and like wanting to please your parents
when you're young and wanting to and
like sexual hormones and you like boys
and you don't want to like express it
because everyone's like try to tap that
down it's awkward yeah yeah this is very
real it just is not as like i guess uh
what what does it need to be like
spelled out so that it looks like how
you need it to look how you look
it's called metaphors yeah i think
there's
like i was more interested in in those
correlations than i was the
you know anything with like the actual
ritual of the panda and stuff i like i
like everything it represented i liked
everything and metaphorically talked
about it was like amusing but i wasn't
that into that whole goal of like we got
to go to four town like that right
wasn't that engaging to me right but i
was going it probably means something
deeper than just going to see the ban
right i think some people might check it
because i had to remind myself that like
there's probably a much deeper meaning
to this whole action of making sure
she's going to go to this concert you
know right like how she's going about it
too the journey of you know embracing
herself and accepting herself doing what
she wants to do is really what it's
about but yeah that whole ending scene
with the panda and the
mirror dimension
was really it was really beautiful it
was really making me a really misty and
i was really crying a lot there yeah
that's a good message i mean it's like
all of the generations up to our mom
like you can see that they're all pretty
much kind of the same person followed a
path yeah didn't find themselves
and then she did and then she meets with
her ancient ancient grandma who's like i
didn't follow that path either well i
think it worked best as like this like
slice of life thing that had this larger
than life fantasy quality with the panda
i like the simplicity of that yeah so
when it got like really big in the end i
felt like the message started getting a
bit
muddled a little bit tiny bit except for
they all went back to being without the
panda except for her yeah yeah so they
let her have her own choice so yeah like
it made sense to me it just when it got
so big of like
like a kaiju battle you know
i agree it was sort of like where where
this is uh a little out of tone i guess
tonally like yeah a little like
i i don't know if it was
needed to be that large i don't think it
needed to go that big i was i didn't i
felt like they needed it like adventure
and we needed to be big and then she
needs to like almost die and then we
have to like pull her back and ho town
comes back and apparently there's still
kids behind the rubble
like that we're like we saw all these
like big pandas and one the one almost
died and they were like we knew oh town
would come back they're like peeking out
i was like all right that's a little
that's a little weird it was still very
entertaining though it was entertaining
like it was amusing it was cool to look
at but i did start getting like yeah i
feel like it's kind of losing some of
the the part the heart of it that i
really love with the magic was the
the simplicity of it while i agree like
yeah it's a really like
pretty simple
story and it's not something that
because they usually like pixar when
they want to go weighty are going live
really existential like wall-e or some
[ __ ] yeah before they go like really
just like traumatic opening like up yeah
like really get you hard
there is a post-credit scene
[Music]
[Music]
dad's like tyler
he's he's still a little repressed but
yeah he was a bully
all right we'll finish reviewing it in
three two one so dad likes four town too
who wouldn't like four town i know
everybody i thought it was gonna be more
90s leaning because like they said in 94
and i thought it would be like oh it is
yeah at the beginning it's in 94 and
that's why there was the best oh okay
tara is so old she thinks nsync came out
like five years ago
she's like backstreet boys is still
around right
genie in a bottle from christina it just
came out maybe
those are good songs those are great
songs they're great bands man great
bands okay now it's all about k-pop
which is great
which is great actually it's a lot much
more impressive
but yeah
um
yeah i i mean i it's weird like this
guy's a good critic scoring and i saw
the audience had like a pretty big
divide with it and i'm like i guess it's
just not like
i wouldn't say it's
like bottom t i mean it's not top tier
pixar for me but it's not i wouldn't be
like it's bottom tier no it's pretty
good i feel like people just don't get
metaphors or they don't like understand
the message there like maybe mom didn't
need to change into a panda like maybe
it needed to be like the kid stays but
her and mom come together i mean we all
knew that her and mom would come
together in the end yeah and i feel like
uh
i don't know i i don't know why people
wouldn't i feel like if you make it
through to the end of the movie
you you have to be like yeah there's a
good message there yeah maybe they just
didn't they didn't want mom to like go
go back to who she was even though she
didn't fully but she did make the choice
to be without her pen and keep it in
like all the rest of them did yeah they
kept it in a gray area yeah which i
appreciate the gray area because
um like if mom was like no i'm not i'm
not going i'm going to stick by my
daughter and also keep the panda i'm
like no that would be out of character
not saying that that's what people
wanted why they didn't like the movie
they probably just didn't like it for
other reasons but
well i could see why people wouldn't
like i mean because of the fact i think
there's the the
the thing of its pixar so you kind of
add a little bit more critical eye on
what you expect what you expect yeah
yeah because it does follow it this does
not follow the tropes of pixar no and it
doesn't have quite the
the well this is more like the onward
category like you've seen onward yeah
like yeah or something yeah um
but not something like soul
yeah which
like those are like it's like elevated
pixar yeah and while i think this it go
it still has the impressive animation
and really great voice work and stuff
um yeah for the most part it felt like
i don't
i really think it's beautiful to look at
at the same time i'm not like i needed
to have seen this in the theaters
no no no no no no good i still would
recommend it like
i recommend it i think there's so much
great things in it it's also funny a lot
of the time too oh yeah yeah i mean
what's that movie about where they're
angry and they're the marbles that
represent anger inside out thank you so
much
that movie i was like oh i wish i would
have seen this in theaters because i
don't think yeah i watch it on my tv
that i feel very strongly like that
movies i feel more strongly connected to
like maybe those classic like pixars i
mean obviously all the other ones like
up i can't even
i can't watch that movie more than
more than twice i will never watch it
again it's one of my most favorite
movies but i'm like it's too emotional
for me
but um
this i don't think i'd be like click on
it and be like i'm gonna watch it again
but i think i would tell people
to be like oh you should definitely
watch it to be like to get the message
yeah see a different thing from pixar
and what they can do because the message
is still there and pixar is very good at
giving lessons i think and you know it's
it is interesting i i don't know like to
me it just threw me like for a loop when
they are talking about like
reproductive qualities
right
i'm like oh i'm so used to seeing i
guess now right in in typical movies
with real like a kids movie you're not
gonna be yeah and like a kid's animated
movie i'm like it's pg and i'm like okay
that makes more sense right because when
you weren't talking about like going
like going like because it's also like a
big puberty metaphor this whole film
yeah like this is yeah it's not even
just a metaphor it's just that's what's
happening she's going through puberty
right and so when they are talking about
that it's you know i could see how the
context of the whole panda thing is all
representative of that one especially
when they make
the scene the introduction scene of that
about her having a period like right the
mom's registering what's happening right
and to me to just the fact that they're
even having that discussion in an
animated kids movie was like
oh i did not expect this movie to even
bring up such subjects yeah like it was
surprising yeah um but
i don't know if that like upsets
so
groups of the i don't want to spend
forever trying to die like what do
people like
but i was i was actually i give it
credit for um i'm being willing to do
that yeah yeah i feel like i'm
desensitized as i watch so many things
and there's so many films out there that
i guess like 13 year olds aren't
watching but maybe like teenagers could
watch where they do deal with like oh
someone helping the girl with their
period it's awkward for mom or dad they
don't have to deal with it but um
i guess in an animated it's like
everyone goes to see pixar or pixar is
regarded as safe
and they don't do too many topics at
least not as of like and maybe until now
that are like reaching that like
puberty and stuff like that where she's
like all the details of it all the
details of it and her drawing like him
and getting like heated and
yeah and then talking boys and yada yada
uh yeah i guess you're right i'm like oh
that's weird that they haven't done that
until now
where it's more in your face which this
one was yeah obvious so i'm thinking
about it in terms of like if i saw it on
like anything else i would be like okay
yeah but for this for like a disney
pixar like oh wow they're doing it yeah
she did it yeah that's what i said in
the 90s because
she could just access the internet and
for all her freakish
oh right furry desires right mermaids
yeah
i wanted to go on my phone and
look online some some max free websites
here
they had to limit themselves
ah i did think the
the friends i love what the friends
represented as a support group and what
it feels like to have your friends as
family but not feel like the ones you
could really love and feel the love and
trust from is your your actual family i
think that's a really relatable thing
yeah like while i watch this i i can
definitely be like yeah it's nothing
more targeted towards a female audience
than
someone like me at the same time i'm
like all the emotional things the
context of all the emotional
surroundings i think are very relatable
for for men yeah who don't just go
anger
don't push it down you know
feel the need to cry once in a while
like a real man yeah
oh god k-pop yeah
so you get ladies is it just that that's
move that and say you cry
i cry
i cry
i think it worked
everybody's wet out there yeah
with emotions in their eyes yes
sure
[Laughter]
that's what she meant
yeah no no it's not we're not gonna get
demonetized no no no no no no no one
stupid joke but from the eyes duh
no when you cry a lot it was wet on your
face what all in your face everywhere is
what i meant
that doesn't sound good either so we'll
just stop we'll just try to stop oh stop
staying wet
stop saying what and we'll be fine
okay i'm gonna change subjects you can
make a panda cinematic universe like
this ah
first in kung fu panda oh
yeah
yeah yeah what you like meeting they get
no
that's they cross
over two different they did it with the
spiderman
they can do it with the pandas one is
universal and one is disney they'll
never come together it's kung fu panda
universal yeah
all right well
there's your lesson for today universal
versus disney i give it like a seven
point eight out of ten hey that's pretty
good
yeah yeah
i'll give it a seven
out of ten even though you didn't ask i
think he wanted me to give probably a
rating or he was like forget it
you know i felt that once the man has
stated that yeah the ratings you don't
need a woman do we really need
sure i get it
no big deal
seven
out of ten
okay whatever makes you feel better that
peaked in there yeah okay right
so they'll
yeah
listen guys uh follow tara on her social
media yeah she has to drive home now oh
my god oh wait you gotta wait an hour
it's gonna be like a long drive la
traffic baby
here for it um
hey but tara can you help me do it
tara can you shout out our friend deonte
aka tongue punch fartbox
deonte tongue punch
[Music]
think is that good i think adam all the
times we have tried to finding inventive
ways to shout out tongue punch park
pucks
not once did we actually try to do
wow they didn't actually try to do it
i'm telling fart bucks with my mouth all
right deontay you need to come over to
my patreon baby now leave them just for
a week give me
the one monthly payment you can come
right back just you know because i
understand you
and maybe they don't do i apparently not
they don't i thought we had something
but clearly we have grown apart and now
you i'm locking it down
you guys gotta share your punch fart
boxes thank you deontay